[Music]
welcome
my name is andrew sandberg and i'm a
researcher at the future of humanity
institute
at oxford university and of about a year
ago
i met my co-author thomas moynihan this
was the first time
we met and the last time so far because
then covet arrived
and we were supposed to work on another
thing and then
we discovered this wonderful question
what about wire heading
what about the myth of putting
electrodes into the heads of rat
that causes addiction what does this
tell us about
artificial intelligence computers
civilization
and how we think about what it means to
be an agent
and as a being that can feel pleasure
so i'm very happy to give his talk and i
would like to acknowledge
thomas and the hard work in making this
possible
and you should all read his excellent
book on existential risk
so the story begins a while ago
when people started worrying about the
future
and in particular when many people
started worrying that
we might go down the wrong route so
here's a quote
from omahandra and the leading
thinker about the safety of artificial
intelligence and
when he was talking to fellow futurists
they all
brought up that maybe we would become
wireheads
and then he refers to these experiments
where rat were giving the ability to
directly play
stimulate the pleasure center by pushing
a lever and the rats push the lever
until they died
and they ignore everything food or sex
to do this
and you have probably heard this story
before
because it's part now of the myths of
our culture
and this talk is going to try to look a
little bit about the story
before that and how we ended up thinking
about wire heading
long before any rats actually got
electrodes into ukrainia
and how it might affect our actual
future and what it might tell us about
how we quite often
have some news ideas and then we get
some science that we match on the two
and say
yeah what and we told you so here it's
evidence that this is an
actual problem so the real
classic paper about this and that is in
1954 and
you can say that in 1954 james olds
discovered a pleasure
so if we in a look at the paper
especially a sequel paper in scientific
america
that describes it a bit uh you have this
standard setup
there is an electrode in the septal
region of the brain of a rat the rat
presses a lever gets us in a stimulating
signal and then the question is what
happens
and old said already a bit earlier in 54
found that
if he stimulated the rats they seem to
want to get more stimulation
in that spot so then he and miller
followed that
with his paper and it degenerated the
bit of science the interesting thing
that was going on here
is of course but this became construed
stimulating the pleasure symptoms as i'm
going to come back to
this was actually somewhat revolutionary
at the time
also of course it led to a lot of
thinking where people were
starting to envision this not just in
rats but in humans
and in civilizations before i really get
started i like to point out that
there is a difference here between the
traditional fears about
vice and addiction already in the in the
odyssey there is the island of the lotus
eaters where they're just
while away their time in pleasure and
certainly any civilization that has
encountered anything addictive
will know that that's a bit risky what
makes wire heading interesting is that
this concept that using techno science
we can make something that is supremely
addicting
and as a will show we might even worry
about this
ham civilization itself so the link here
to technoscience
make it much more far-reaching
now the fun thing here is of course
wireheading was around long before the
rats
so all around him when alessandro volta
invented the first batteries
he tried of course stimulating himself
and got electric shocks
uh and he didn't like that very much and
he tried sending an electric shock
through his head
and they concluded that was really bad
he felt it
very disagreeable and felt like maybe
something is boiling here
you shouldn't do that but others didn't
take that safety advice uh seriously
you and wilhelm ritter a german chemist
started experimenting systematically
with
giving himself electric shocks and he
seemed to have become
somewhat addicted to it he kept on
stimulating every part of his body and
at first we might say maybe that's
systematic a bit like
an entomologist who's been trying to get
started by the most
painful insects and create that in the
pain scale
but most of his contemporaries started
noticing that he was
behaving as he was addicted he was
getting disheveled
he was not caring too much about friends
and indeed he was
reporting that stimulation of a sexual
organs could be quite pleasurable
and eventually died young and many
ascribed that too
well he was just giving himself too much
electrical stimulation
now what happened when later in the
19th century was that people did a
careful study
of electrical stimulation of the nervous
system gradually it became clear
how nerves worked using electrical
signals tools for stimulation were
developed
in the 1930s enfield did the
stimulation on the surface of the brain
of patients during local anesthesia
and could report how they experienced it
tools for implanting electrodes were
developed gradually a field of
electrophysiology was maturing
at the same time in psychology the
dominant uh
paradigm and that was by the behaviorism
so behaviorism basically organ you
shouldn't talk about inner experience
that's unscientific
that's not how we do it we can only look
at what we can
observe and make operational and in
particular saying that you have a desire
to do something
yeah what does that actually correspond
to and people had this
concept of drive reduction of motivation
which is basically a cybernetic theory
so you have some resource let's say that
you're
starting to have low blood sugar that
means that
now you get a disagreeable sensation
because
you're feeling hungry and that goes away
if you eat something
so you get a feedback loop that causes
behavior that makes you eat
similar for all the other desires and
this
is basically the idea that the only
reason we do anything
is to return to homeostasis there is
this
baseline and once you're there you don't
want to do anything
now this of course leads to an
interesting
uh question but if you want to
talk about what the rats are doing then
you should expect it and to just if
there is
something it can do that doesn't
actually remove
any hunger or first it will probably not
do anything
but that's the opposite what happens
when you stimulated the rats
instead they got very very excited and
seem to want to do more
so this is where old's experiment kind
of broke
the older mode and he actually
showed that it looks like the rats like
it and he could show it
in both in a scientific way but also in
the scientific american paper he was
actually talking about pleasure centers
something orthodox of behaviorists that
time would say that's unscientific
and later on in his autobiography he
even pointed out that yeah
the rats actually did seem to enjoy it
you can actually recognize
the rat facial expressions if you're
around them enough
so what happened was this was part of
what torpedoed
the classical behaviorist theory and of
drive reduction
then there is another interest of him
that's the myth of self-starvation
so in the original experiments the rats
definitely didn't die they were spending
an enormous amount of effort pressing
the lever
quite often several times per second uh
but
it wasn't that they just did that and
then
they fell ill because we didn't want to
eat
instead what seemed to happen is that
there is a competition against other
drives
so in later experiments people started
recognizing that
actually if there is a choice between
self-stimulation of food
sometimes self-stimulation wins and
there are
indeed the experiments that do lead to
malnourishment
so it seems like yeah it's not like it
totally wins
but there is a competition just like we
might have a competition between
going to a lecture versus eating versus
playing computer games we need to
decide which of our drives to we let win
but it's not so easy and especially some
of them like when these
brain stimulation seem to be much
stronger then of course
it's kind of clear that you could expand
beyond the rodent
so already in 1968 there is
another myth that shows up and that is
the story about the dolphin
that um they kind of got brain
stimulated to death
delighted himself to death after an
all-night orgy of pleasure
its very sixties to continue watching
this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you